entreprendre daniela connaît bien en
2003 elle décide de quitter son poste
d'expert comptable à auchan pour lancer
sa propre entreprise
elle se tourne alors vers la décoration
sa passion depuis toujours et créer dany
décoration à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est vraiment une envie qu à un moment
donné de se détacher de d'un travail
quotidien peut un peu routinier et c'est
une star par contre de combattant quand
même créé une entreprise et faut être
tenace et ne pas ne pas perdre l'espoir
et continuer à avancer pour monter son
entreprise
elle rejoint alors créactive
l'association aide les femmes depuis
2003 à concrétiser leurs projets à
l'époque elles étaient 7
aujourd'hui elles sont près d'une
cinquantaine kreactive c'est un
incubateur de savoir et de partage et
c'est des femmes extraordinaires qui
entraient leur entreprise et ou qui sont
en cours de création et qui vient
chercher en fait à un soutien une écoute
parce que nous on sait écouter en fait
et il y en a beaucoup qui ont rentré
dans l'association qui ont réussi à
créer leur entreprise grâce aux aides
des membres donc ça c'est très important
si elle ne compte pas ses heures elle
forme volontiers des apprentis une
priorité pour cette chef d'entreprise
fur et à mesure peut-être qu'on a aussi
des futurs entrepreneurs
donc si nous en tant que femme et chef
d'entreprise on transmet pas à cette
envie on leur donne pas tous les outils
comment voulez que les jeunes créent ils
peuvent pas un tiers des chefs
d'entreprise aujourd'hui sont des femmes
alors mesdames n'hésitez plus
lancez-vous objectifs du gouvernement
pouvoir atteindre les 40% d'ici 2017